- So, do you do anything
for Valentine's Day?
Do you go all out or do you just chill?
- No, well, you know
what I used to do a lot,
was I was always waitressing
on Valentine's Day.
- Me too.
- Yeah, 'cause I was a waitress
for a really long time.
But the real fun is actually
the day before Valentine's,
which is--
- [Kelly] I know where
you're going with this.
- Yes.
- That's when you.
- That's the day you
have the most cash sales,
because that's--
- Because people don't want
you to follow that trail,
'cause they're not with their person.
Yes!
- That's what my restaurant managers
- It's mistress day, yeah.
- That's the day.
- Yeah.
It's a real thing if
you've ever waited tables.
It's so sad, but it's real.
Like and they pay with cash
and you're like mmm-kay.
- You're like yep.
Like why are all my sales cash?
- Yeah.
I spent a lot of holidays
waiting tables as well.
And people don't get
how hard you work at it.
They're always like I need this now.
I'm like so do the other seven tables.
Slow your role.
- Everybody needs somethin'.
- Yeah, turns out you aren't special.
I have to wait on everyone.
But anyway, I was a
good waitress, I swear.
(laughing)
But did you have any other jobs,
like before hitting it big?
- Oh well, I was a personal
trainer for about two weeks.
- I worked at a gym.
But I would have never
been a personal trainer.
- I shouldn't have been.
(laughing)
- So, you like really, that takes a lot.
Like I would never, no.
Did you feel comfortable doing that?
- Nope.
- You have to know all the things.
- No comfort.
- [Kelly] No comfort.
- No motivation.
It's like people were
coming to me to be motivated
and I didn't have anything for them.
(laughing)
- You're like, you know
what, do 10 times, or eight,
I don't care.
Like yeah.
Do 10 reps or none.
I don't care what you do.